this is your your uh the way I do my uh
test the button my testibility is always
reflective of my Kempo trains you always
obey
uh the center line you don't go outside
of the outer rim just to put it simply
uh you always start from point of origin
and you use economy in motion okay so
here we have I don't care so here I have
um
his weapon okay you're gonna strike at
my face okay so there it goes
do that side again slower one two
so if you look at tessabaki one is my
other pair is my first Prairie then two
is the other hand
so it's the same punch again solar one
two
but now we have to adhere okay same side
again so it's one two and we're stuck
here that's what I'm looking for I'm
looking for in Center so you can project
that way but obeying yin yang I'll take
the scapula
[Music]
connection to me means adhesion right
there and again right there
um
I don't want you to discount it okay so
uh for example
he does the same punch
and you can shove him into the wall and
now you're attacking the back okay or
you can shove them into anyone else but
I'm just using this mechanically
to understand hands go from point of
origin and I'm stuck right there
hands point of origin stop
and then projecting out okay that's what
we're working on
so now go ahead
now if I have that uh adhesion there it
gives go ahead it gives a slight little
acceleration you see as I use it to the
end of its yawn face
so now I don't have to just push
I can use it to generate opposing forces
into the knee strike okay as opposed to
I'm just out of the way and I I kind of
hit there I'm kind of throwing them in
there and when I throw them in there I
increase force and impact on the knee
strike and I also make sure his Center
is committed to the angle of attack of
the knee strike okay so I don't want you
to just go like this go and you're out
of the way and throwing it I I am
literally same thing that little thing
that I'm doing there
is the same thing I'm doing into them
okay
nothing changes on the cross nothing
will change on the cross okay so uh he's
not going to step forward he's going to
shuffle forward and do this do the
strike okay so nothing changes on the
cross we still have yeah
and they're still doing the double
Factor everything boom and you're
throwing them into that new Skype
okay try
okay okay so the same uh let's do the
cross stuff so here's what I meant on
the on the cross shot so I'd keep
whatever side I normally fight with
forward and as the cross Comes This is
Where I I would deviate that way okay
you don't either you don't have to trade
sides unless you want to it's fine
okay
so fight in your fighting stance okay so
uh he's gonna do his thing
and I'm seeking an adhesion at some
point
boom
and even as I strike
pool right with my knee sorry I forgot
boom I still have dead adhesion okay
if he saws like that which is very
likely from the strike okay oh my souls
he comes back up
all right
whom he stalls it's right here
but you can't undo the connection or you
won't find it okay try it okay so if you
look at your your testibility right and
I go here I don't have my other hand go
here
the other hand is going to cover load
you see and then when it goes up the the
ham in this case I would go to the back
you see
but you're always going to have your
outer rim covered in some sort of high
low and that's where the trapping comes
in okay so as he goes go slow so I can
talk okay so boom when this ends here
this hand should drop okay protecting
against that leg
you can't even hit with it before your
knee right but my hand will be low
because the other hand is high and I'm
not in the back it's just automatic what
happens
here right so boom that's why that hand
is right there for that one that's why I
went there
but this high low not only adds coverage
but it helps me track right now you guys
are here
and you're going grab
here
my opening triangles of the high low
will trap do you see
you won't have time but you don't need
you can watch when I if I even close the
wrist hand
you can watch when I do if I do okay A
lot of times I don't
okay just in the two adhesions
here
and I'm just entering
in there okay because closing your hands
and first it's making you look for
something as opposed to feel for
something and that is taking time that's
taking time and then you're taking time
to grab instead of just trapping an
intern okay try it again here here's
what what I'm trying to get you guys to
do is in the game remember sometimes you
can adhere sometimes you can project
sometimes you have to follow and
sometimes you have to protect your
center line but every time you follow
you take it back to an adhesion point or
every time you protect your Center Line
you take it into an adhesive point okay
so we're out of the game now and we're
just working on that okay so slow just
to summarize when he's coming in
I adhered here so here
I don't I'm not touching it I'm not
starting at education but I'm protecting
my Center Line
okay so he's the Texas Center Line and I
is here okay and I keep it hearing even
in the strikes and things like that okay
so here on this one I'm going to go here
and I'm going to adhere he's touching my
shoulder you so watch watch
you see
I'll take my shoulder off don't lean on
me and here I don't lean on me
lift your arm out of the way
here the arm on his chest come to this
side Sean my forearm on his chest
and don't lean on me yet
and I wanted to show the arm you
understand the arm is going to do the
adhesion
you see
so combined
I have my shoulder
and my arm and I adhere
[Music]
he strikes in here
here is just the hour pairing home and
here
and you're going to find kaita Noggin
but you have to be stuck
thank you
[Music]
okay let's try it
okay so remember the art is is a
Reconciliation of external internal we
focus on the internal because we're so
external heavy okay but you want to
combine both so uh we'll do the end
when he does the strike I'm not going to
stop him that he he I want to keep him
going with the adhesion do you get it so
don't look too he goes and you'll hear
yourself in him
you're going to hit
and hurt
[Music]
hit and turn
and then it doesn't take so much okay
and when you're on this arm
you have a couple choices
for where this arm goes here if he's
tough like that I'm gonna hold the elbow
here
okay because the arm is trapped
if he's up and then I'll hold the lap
the lap does the same thing
[Music]
they'll come up here you know opening up
your ribs
punch okay
so again
boom
moving
and then the leg will present itself
because one hand is high so the other
hand is going to be low
there it is right there
foreign